It's important for us to be realists and not
idealists, we have to be cautiously optimistic
and pragmatic, not delusional, utopian, and
in that vein, it's important that we all understand
as we think about the next months and certainly
the next couple of years, that there is simply
not going to be the unity that Joe Biden campaigned
on and called for in his inauguration speech.
We've talked about this a little bit more.
And later today, we're going to be looking
at one piece of why, which is that thanks
to the cult of Trump, there are now people
in positions of power, like Lauren Bobber,
like Madison Cawthorn, like Marjorie Taylor
Green, who don't know anything.
They are simply political characters playing
roles.
They are not lawmakers.
They are not thinkers.
And unity isn't part of the character they've
been hired to play.
And by hired, I mean voted in by wacky Trump
Republicans in November of twenty twenty.
That's one side.
But there is another side to this, which is
that Joe Biden is going to do things that
will disgust not half of the country, but
a large enough portion of it that a contingent
of Republican elected officials will stand
in the way and say no, no matter what.
We actually are seeing amazingly significant
approval of, for example, Joe Biden's first
week, five days uncovered.
And we'll talk about that a little bit later.
But even significant approval, like 70 percent,
which in this country is in credit.
It's almost unanimous approval for the standards
we have here.
The 30 percent that hates it are represented
by some of the most radical members of Congress.
And so there is not going to be unity.
Conservative Rich Lowry wrote a piece in Politico
called No, There Won't Be Unity, and his sub
headline explains his take on why, which is,
quote, On substance, Biden is not going to
pursue a consensus, bipartisan, bipartisan
agenda, but a progressive one.
I don't know that I'd characterize Biden's
agenda as progressive.
It's certainly to the left of recent Democratic
presidents.
But what Rich Lowry is saying is that Joe
Biden is going to do things that the right
will never accept.
Joe Biden wants unity around us, deciding
as a country to follow science instead of
cartoonish denialism on covid 30 or so percent
of the country doesn't want that.
This isn't a both sides thing, merely differences
of opinion.
Imagine if 30 percent of the country said
we don't agree with the laws of gravity.
You'd say, OK, well, you're going to end up
getting a lot of bumps on the head and people
falling out of buildings.
But the idea of ignoring something that simply
is you don't really have a choice.
And Joe Biden is going with reality on covid
and about 30 percent of the country doesn't
accept it.
So you're not going to get unity.
Joe Biden is doing things that are going to
be characterized as stirring the pot, literally
the term Rich Lowry uses in the Politico piece.
Last week, I played a clip for you from Fox
News of anchor Ainslee Arehart saying Joe
Biden called for unity and yet he did executive
orders that go against how Trump governed.
Well, that's a framework where unity is quite
literally impossible.
Now, unity doesn't have to be.
We agree with Joe Biden on everything.
Unity should be Biden one.
Yes, he really did win up.
Many of them don't accept that.
But OK, but Biden, one unity can be since
Biden won.
Let's try it.
Let's not actively obstruct everything Joe
Biden tries to do and let's evaluate where
we are in six months empirically.
But they're not going to do that.
And so what Republicans are already saying,
there won't be unity because Joe Biden is
doing stuff.
They are right about half of it, which is
there won't be unity, but it's more because
of the country being divided culturally to
such a degree.
One side wants to get actual experts and scientists
involved in solving some of the biggest challenges
we have.
The other side wants cartoon character, right
wingers who want to bring guns on the House
floor and feed every false conspiratorial
notion they can come up with.
Unity truly isn't possible in that scenario,
but it isn't because Joe Biden is doing things
Biden's president.
That's what presidents do when they get to
work, when they don't go golfing.
Twenty percent of the time they get to work
and they try to do the things they campaigned
on.
But that's not the story being told on right
wing media, which is another reason why there
won't be unity.
I'm not challenging FOX News is right to exist.
I'm not saying Newsmax should be.
Hold off the air, I'm pointing out that they
foment the lack of unity by putting out nonsense
like Biden, doing the things he promised to
do is divisive.
Joe Biden doing the things he ran on doing,
which got him elected, is now being called
a divisive action.
And understand that with that is your starting
point.
The possibility of unity doesn't exist because
you're not dealing in actually evaluating
policy.
You're not dealing and saying, oh, Joe Biden
did this.
Let's see what the results are.
You're engaging in hyperbole and non-thinking
reactivity.
And so Rich Lowry is right.
There's not going to be unity, but not because
Joe Biden is some extreme progressive left
winger.
It's because 30 percent of this country simply
refuses to accept reality and they have enough
support among the House and Senate that there
will be actual elected official Republicans
who will do what they can to get in the way
of anything Joe Biden wants to do.
And anything Joe Biden gets done, they will
say it's bad apriori and Joe Biden should
be punished because he's doing something different
than what Republicans want him to do.
It's looking very ugly.
The good news is it seems that Democrats understand
this and Bernie Sanders understands this and
they are ready to simply pass things by simple
majority ignoring Republicans.
Let's talk about that next.